YES YES, THAT ADDITION.
RAYMOND ARROYO EXPANDS IT ALL IN
SEEN AND UNSEEN.
BUT FIRST, MIGHTY JOE MANCHIN.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
"ANGLE"."
DEMOCRATS WANT AMERICANS TO
THINK THAT THEY REPRESENT THE
VANGUARD AGAINST ALL EXTREMISTS,
AND THAT THEY ONLY GO TO
POLITICAL WAR WHEN THEY NEED TO
DEFEAT ALLEGED RADICALS LIKE
DONALD TRUMP.
THE TRUTH IS THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS BECOME A
HAVEN FOR FAR LEFT FANATICS, AND
LIKE ALL FANATICS, THEY DEMAND
COMPLETE AND TOTAL CONFORMITY OF
THOUGHT ON ALL OF THEIR PET
ISSUES, FROM THE MINIMUM WAGE TO
IMMIGRATION AMNESTY, TO THINGS
LIKE TRANSGENDER RIGHTS.
GET IN MIND, OR RISK GETTING
SMEARED.
SUCH HAS BEEN THE EXPERIENCE OF
WEST VIRGINIA
SENATOR JOE MANCHIN.
NOW THAT HE HAS DECIDED TO MAKE
THE OBVIOUS CHOICE TO OPPOSE
PRESIDENT BIDEN’S OMB PICK.
KNAUF MANCHIN’S DECISION IS NOT
ARBITRARY, IT WAS SENSIBLE.
LIKE SO MANY OTHER BIDEN CABINET
AND SOME CABINET PICKS LIKE DEB
HAALAND FOR INTERIOR,
XAVIER BECERRA, AND RACHEL
LEVINE, HHS, IT’S AN INSANELY
STUPID AND POLARIZING CHOICE.
A VENOMOUS HACK, TANDEN HAS
SPRAYED CONSERVATIVES INCLUDING
SITTING SENATORS WITH GRATUITOUS
AND GROUNDLESS ATTACKS.
SHE IS ALSO A CONSPIRACY
THEORIST AND RUSSIA HOAX
SUPER-SPREADER.
AND IF THAT’S NOT ENOUGH CAN HER
NOMINATION, SHE HAS ALSO
DISPLAYED TERRIBLE JUDGMENT.
ACCORDING TO BUZZFEED, AS THE
PRESIDENT OF CENTER FOR
AMERICAN PROGRESS, TANDEN OUTED
AN ANONYMOUS STAFFER WHO HAD
ACCUSED HER MANAGER OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT.
AND SHE DID IT DURING A STAFF
MEETING, NO LESS.
TEN YEARS EARLIER, AS THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN AGE, TANDEN
REPORTEDLY PUNCHED A LIBERAL
REPORTER WHO ASKED HILLARY ABOUT
HER SUPPORT FOR THE IRAQ WAR.
WHEN SHE WAS PRESSED ABOUT THE
INCIDENT, TANDEN TOLD
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," "I DIDN’T
SLOG HIM, I PUSHED HIM."
THE QUESTION HERE SHOULD END BE
"WHY IS JOE MANCHIN OPPOSING
TANDEN FOR A CABINET LEVEL
POST?"
THE QUESTION SHOULD BE, "WHY THE
HELL DID JOE BIDEN EVER PICK A
LEFT-WING HATCHET WOMAN IN THAT
POSITION IN THE FIRST PLACE?"
OF COURSE, THE LADIES OF CABLE
CAN’T CONCEIVE OF THE FACT THAT
TANDEN WAS A CHOICE, SO INSTEAD,
THEY JUST DO IT THEY ALWAYS DO.
THEY PLAY THE GENDER CARD.
>> HER HISTORY OF HAVING SAID
THINGS LIKE, OH, CALLING
MITCH McCONNELL VOLDEMORT FOR
CALLING TED CRUZ HEARTLESS, THAT
IS WHAT VIOLATES THIS NEW WILL
AND, IN LINE HE DID NOT APPLY TO
CONSIDERING DUDES NOMINATED BY
TRUMP.
>> SEXISM?
>> DOUBLE STANDARD.
>> ALL OF THIS LED NOTABLE
CONSERVATIVE BILL KRISTOL TO SAY
OF TANDEN, "I FEEL LIKE THERE’S
A LITTLE BIT OF SEXISM GOING ON
HERE."
>> Laura: SO WEAK.
WHY GO THERE?
WHY NOT JUST DEFEND THE
NOMINATION OF SUBSTANTIVE
GROUNDS.
I CAN TELL YOU WHY.
BECAUSE TANDEN’S QUALIFICATIONS
ARE REALLY FLIMSY, THAT’S WHY.
RAISING MONEY FOR LEFT-WING
CAUSES AND ATTACKING REPUBLICANS
ON THE INTERNET HARDLY QUALIFIES
YOU TO RUN THE OFFICE OF
MANAGEMENT AND BUDGET.
BUT IF THE SEXISM LINE ISN’T
SELLING, WELL, YOU CAN COUNT ON
THE DEMOCRATS TO REVERT TO THEIR
OLD STANDBY: RACISM.
AS IN, ANYONE WHO CRITICIZES ANY
OF THE PRESIDENT’S NOMINATIONS
IS A RACIST.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN’S NOMINEES OF
COLOR WHO ARE FACED OUTSIDE
OPPOSITIONS.
I GUESS IF THIS WAS BIPARTISAN,
THAT WAS OKAY BY OLD
JOE MANCHIN.
WHAT IS UP WITH YOU, MANCHIN?
>> Laura: OF COURSE, PEOPLE
LIKE JOY REID ARE SOME OF THE
MOST ILLIBERAL PEOPLE ON THE
PLANET.
AND MEANWHILE, OVER AT CNN,
TODAY, DAYTIME HOST WAS
BEMOANING THE SIMPLE MATH OF THE
U.S. SENATE.
>> IT’S UNFORTUNATE THAT HE
COMES FROM THE STATE WHICH IS
NOT PARTICULARLY REPRESENTATIVE
OF MOST OF THE COUNTRY.
IT’S A LARGELY RURAL STATE, AND
A MINERAL PRODUCING STATE, AND
SO MUCH OF THE GDP OF THE
COUNTRY COMES ELSEWHERE -- FROM
ELSEWHERE.
BUT IT IS WHAT IT IS.
>> Laura: YOU KNOW WHAT ELSE
IS WHAT IT IS?
THAT YOU, SIR, ARE AN ODIOUS
SNOB WHO REGARD TO WEST AND
MANCHIN THE SAME WAY, YOU KNOW,
THEY REGARD PRESIDENT TRUMP, AS
NOW WHAT TERRIFIES TODAY’S
DEMOCRATS I THINK THE MOST IS
THE PROSPECT THAT COME
NOVEMBER 2022, THEY AND THEIR
JOB KILLING POLICIES ARE GOING
TO BE EXPOSED.
THAT MILLIONS OF VOTERS WILL
DECIDE THEY WANT THEIR FREEDOM
BACK.
AND THAT ALL THE RADICAL
NONSENSE BIDEN’S TEAM PUSHED
FAILED SPECTACULARLY, WHICH OF
COURSE, IT WILL.
DEMOCRATS HAVE THE SLIMMEST OF
MARGINS IN THE SENATE, AND
THOUGHTS, THEY ARE MOVING
RADICAL EXECUTIVE ORDERS AND
DESTRUCTIVE LEGISLATION THROUGH
AS FAST AS THEY CAN.
THEY ARE DESPERATE TO PREVENT
ANYONE WITH TRUMP’S VIEWS FROM
WINNING NATIONAL OFFICE EVER
AGAIN.
THUS, THEIR INTRODUCTION OF THE
SO-CALLED "FOR THE PEOPLE" ACT,
WHICH IS ANYTHING BUT.
IF THAT BECOMES LAW, IT WOULD
MANDATE NATIONWIDE, AUTOMATIC,
AND SAME-DAY VOTER REGISTRATION.
WELL, THE FEDS WOULD ALSO BE IN
CONTROL OF EARLY VOTING AND VOTE
BY MAIL.
NO PROBLEM THERE, OF COURSE.
AND IF YOU OPPOSE THIS TAKEOVER
OF SENATE AND STATE VOTING, YOU
ARE A --
IF LEFT TO THEIR OWN
DEVICES, REPUBLICANS WILL TRY TO
LIMIT THE ABILITY OF MINORITY
VOTERS TO EXERCISE THEIR
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS TO VOTE.
DEMOCRATS KNOW THAT TRUMP MADE
GAINS WITH MINORITY VOTERS, AND
I’M TELLING YOU, THEY PLAN TO
BLOCK THIS GOING FORWARD BY
STARTING COMMISSIONS TO CLAIM
THAT REPUBLICANS ARE WHITE
SUPREMACISTS HIDING IN SLEEPER
CELLS ALL ACROSS AMERICA.
THEY ARE JUST WAITING, BY THE
WAY, TO BE ACTIVATED.
IT’S ALSO TRANSPARENT, IT’S
PREDICTABLE, AND IT’S TOTALLY
DISHONEST.
AND IN SO MANY OTHER AREAS, AS
IN SO MANY OTHER AREAS,
DEMOCRATS ARE MAKING HUGE
MISTAKES BY VILIFYING PEOPLE
LIKE MANCHIN, WHILE ELEVATING
HARD-CORE RADICALS LIKE TANDEN.
BIDEN IS GOING TO FIND OUT THE
HARD WAY THAT VOTERS, THEY
DIDN’T GIVE HIM A MANDATE TO
REMAKE AMERICA.
HE’S ONLY MANDATE WAS MAYBE TO
DEAL WITH COVID AND REOPEN
AMERICA.
AND WE KNOW DR. FAUCI ISN’T
ABOUT TO LET THAT HAPPEN ANYTIME
SOON.
HISPANIC AND AFRICAN-AMERICAN
VOTERS, LIKE SO MANY AMERICANS,
ARE TIRING OF THESE NONSENSICAL
LOCKDOWNS.
WE HAVE BEEN WARNING YOU ABOUT
THESE SINCE LAPSED APRIL.
AND THEY ARE REALLY WORRIED,
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO THE
SCHOOLS AND THE KIDS.
AND REPUBLICANS WILL BE THERE
EVERY STEP OF THE WAY TO REMIND
THOSE VOTERS, THE PARTY THAT
KEPT THEM LOCKED DOWN.
AND WHICH PARTY WANTED HIM TO BE
FREE.
SO I HAVE TO ASK, WHY DOES
JOE MANCHIN EVEN WANT TO PUT UP
WITH THIS NONSENSE ANYMORE?
THE PARTY OF RADICAL CENTER
OPERATIONS, THAT LEFT HIM A LONG
TIME AGO.
DEMOCRAT LEADERS PATRONIZE AND
HUMOR MANCHIN WHEN THEY NEED HIS
VOTE, BUT AT THIS POINT, IT’S
JUST OBVIOUS THAT THEY SIMPLY
HATE HIM, AND THEY HATE HIS
CONSTITUENTS, AS WELL.
IMAGINE CONTINUING -- FOR
INSTANCE, BEING A MEMBER IN A
CLUB THAT DETESTS YOU AND THE